My accent changes,
I'm terrible,
may bounce up and down that class ladder
like little trees,
football in La,
like when I'm around like sort of like
my girlfriend really torments me for
life.
She's like,
how much I love working class men.
Like when we went to think it was called
Jewsons to pick up some gravel.
I'm sorry,
I'm so sorry that that's my life.
And there's this bloke there called mark
and he came over and wanted to fight
ots.
You laughed at that episode when it a
photo and I was not a lot and I said
goodbye to him in an overly elaborate
way.
Can I even wave to him a second time for
another apartment?
Cherry out the window.
No,
actually I think I might turn off,
but you don't sit at my.
Oh,
I taught our pal.
Good solid of Alpha power.
The tomato sauce,
guidestar.
Bloody Cockney.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
What's going on?
Well,
that's exactly why we change our voices.
Uh,
interestingly,
the more we know this study,
we have to change our voices to talk to
somebody.
So soon as we started talking to each
other without agreeing to do so,
we started to breathe together because
you have to do that is have a
conversation.
You have to coordinate how you breathe
because that lets you time voices going
back and forth,
the turn taking conversation.
So physical,
it really is.
And we also matched the pros,
the pitch and precedent by voices and
the rhythm of our voices.
We start to bring together,
because you've got this very rhythmic.
He's like,
he's like a dance conversation and you
can only do that dance if you start to
align your behavior.
So that has to happen to talk.
And then the more you like someone,
the more you will start to do other
things,
to change your voice,
to bring it towards them.
So there are studies that have shown
that the more a man likes a woman,
well he will raise the pitch of his
voice to be nearer to hers,
just notes.
And everybody's super self conscious
about
right.
And you believe that you'll start to use
the same words.
You start to use the same pronunciation
jeep and start to use the same grammar
as each other and the and the more you
like.
The most communication is here.
That's the whole point of it is that
we're trying to make a connection with
one another.
We're trying to defy the material prison
of our anatomy.
You're feeling trapped and it's the
voice.
This thing that is not really holy or
truly Uba vibration emanating from you.
That is your misery that you've sent out
in the world to make connections and
communication with God.
I'm good at this and I'm just making
this shit up,
but it's always there.
So it's always expressing like a lot of
you that you don't realize and it's also
expressing how you feel about the people
that you're talking to fairly
unavoidably.
Oh No.
I'm going to start watching myself back
on track because one day Sundays we do a
bit of funny bit in my standup show,
right?
Where I talk about when we did this
interview with Jeremy Paxman and one of
the things that we make jokes about,
I'm going to buy way.
I mean me because.
Because I'm mentally ill,
I consider myself for about nine people
might actually have people at work with
her in the room I'm like,
is that I love about how I go through
these different personas when dealing
with Jeremy Paxman,
they start very light and affable.
Then I got really serious and then I get
very sort of either deliberately or not
deliberately,
but unconsciously referencing ethnic
speak rhythms.
Yeah,
very working class based because I
obviously see myself as speaking on
behalf of outsiders and I use it as an
attack technique.
It's very interesting to watch and your
marketing because we can mark similarity
with it.
You can mark difference because.
Yeah,
right.
Because I'm definitely not try.
I don't go.
I knew I'd have to say.
I'm like,
no,
listen,
I'll take you down.
It's like ridiculous.
It's like a grime single,
but it's.
It's still playing your apps,
your eyes marking out your position to
him as clearly and how you're doing
that.
What you're saying.
I'm not like,
I don't particularly want to be you,
God.
I'm just telling my cell phone.